et on a on a plain d'image de fans qui
ont appris la triste nouvelle ce matin
on va regarder ça et je voyais et
courageux voulez vous dire merci d'avoir
excellent mois et vous savez vous ferai
toujours partie de la famille j'ai vite
déchanté
vous serez toujours le bienvenu chez
nous au gouvernement merci j'ai c'est un
deuil
j'ai oublié de vivre c'est terrible
je pensais pas qu'il serait mort si
jeune mais trop triste
l'émotion est énorme c'est un choc
aujourd'hui j'ai pas les mots pour
exprimer ce composant
si tu pas
franchement le choc je n'y fais partie
de notre vie c'est notre idole on l'a
toujours connue en tant que fan j'ai
perdu une grande partie de moi la france
en johnny c'est comme la france sans la
tour eiffel je suis d'accord je peux
travailler aujourd'hui pour venir le
voir parce que je laime c'était
quelqu'un de délicieux extrêmement tiny
deux adorables
c'est ma vie johnny c'est toute une vie
mais ça ne te raconte pas ça se vit
vous inquiète
je pense que c'était une vraie gentille
un grand chanteur cevital des jeunes
merveilleux irremplaçable d'une bête de
scène notre elvis à nous c'est le
meilleur vraiment je t'aime un sacré mec
[Musique]
alors on a avec avec des fans de johnny
et quand je vois là là là vous êtes ému
en voyant les femmes ouais c'est rien
c'est ça a été un moment difficile
aujourd'hui en plus difficiles comme
vous l'a dit gérard louvin et il sera
toujours avec vous tony mindana date but
toujours jugée sur ses terres c'était
quoi vous étiez fan de tony vous avez
été voir beaucoup de concerts à lui mais
on est déjà rencontré oui j'ai été
figurant dans le film de jean-philippe
ouais je suis rien
et alors c'était un moment incroyable
ouais vous lui avez dit que vous avez
dit que vous étiez très très fan de lui
il savait pas ce que dans le tournage
jean-philippe les prix tous les fans des
figurants ce débat je vous dis mais
savez j'ai vu vers moi même nous dit
bonjour ça va réussir à la marche des
jeunes et pékin alors vous aurez votre
vous avez une fille laura et vous avez
un fils qui s'appelle gens fuient dit
jean-philippe donc vous êtes fan absolu
lors alors vous vous avez trente ans et
c'est papa qui vous a donné la passion
de johnny ben en fait c'est toute la
famille à toute la famille est fan
ouais c'est un peu tout se donner ça
donc bah moi depuis cheminée c'est
johnny donc c'est un peu comme de la
famille et à chaque repas il est là
chaque moment avec la chanson l'aura du
coup à ça reste gravé quoi c'est pas un
nom comme ça donnait juste parce qu'ils
font annonce une histoire un peu vous
êtes fan depuis depuis le début de
johnny mais combien de temps du pilat
juin 15 saisons où j'ai 53 ans et jamais
jamais voulu à des suis jamais jamais
vous êtes des toons on sait maintenant
qu est-ce qui vous plaisait chez johnny
la france vit c'est quoi c'est là c'est
la personne c'est la pire chose à faire
c'est sauvé mais l'artiste l'artiste
aussi la personne que vous l'avez
rencontré vous allez impressionnant très
gentil mais imposant dès qu'ils arrivent
tout s'arrête à côté oui c'est ce que
voulait dire par rapport à ses fans
johnny a toujours été d'une extrême
gentillesse et d'une très grande
courtoisie tout à l'heure julien évoqué
effectivement qu'il y avait
du monde devant chez lui et le radar
dans toutes ses propriétés même quand il
avait une villa ici près de paris à côté
la ville a aussi tout ça et se retrouve
qu' il s' arrêter il saluer les fans il
leur parlait savent avait pas froid vrai
pas faim à chaque fois j'étais bluffé
par sa c2 gentillesse il adorait ses
fans est vraiment vous lui rendiez très
bien il salue ça le rendait heureux de
vous y habituer los angeles en 2009 au
moment où l'accident de vider les filles
mourir à l'époque il y avait des
charters entiers de fans qui était parti
là-bas spécialement au cedars sinaï bay
tous hospitalisés et camper devant des
français venus de paris qui avait fait
quand même dix mille kilomètres pour
venir le voir mais spécialement là bas
et qui est des gens qui avaient très peu
de moyens et qui campaient jour et nuit
devant l'hôpital il y avait 200
journalistes également il y avait un
silence sépulcral autour de l'hôpital
c'était très impressionnant l'époque et
c'est vrai que ça avancera qu'on se
rappelle de 2,7 de cet épisode et
isabelle morini-bosc nous arrangerons
idiots qui m'a bouleversé
il avait privatisé une rue et dans cette
rue il ya une quincaillerie et johnny
puisque depuis 17 ans chaque fois qu'il
sort il ya une émeute qui ne fait jamais
ses courses lui même il sait pas ce que
c'est d'aller dans un supermarché
c'est impossible il l'a fait aux états
unis et la devance quincaillerie ou
c'était privatisé il pouvait y aller il
était émerveillé il a parlé aux gens
pendant toute la journée de cette
quincaillerie où on pouvait trouver de
tout je me suis dit c'est dingue
cet homme n'est jamais entré dans une
quincaillerie et on le dit mais alors
vous découvrez sa dubawi j'avais jamais
vu ça
[Applaudissements]
merci merci d'être l'ami alors vous
alors on le sait avoue travailler dans
l'audiovisuel vous allez travailler avec
laurent wauquiez dégâts c'est vrai vous
avez travaillé et j'aurais adoré que
vous donnez une contrat bail ensemble
voilà vous avez vous appelé alvin et je
ne savais pas du tout que vous étiez fan
de johnny vous êtes fan depuis l'âge de
8 ans et plages des vidéos voilà mon
premier concert à bercy en 1990 avec mon
père et ma mère
ouais et jallet et comment vous sentez
aujourd'hui triste vraiment vraiment
vraiment triste parce que bas parce que
c'est passé johnny c'est celui qui a
bercé mon enfance et qui après a bercé
ma vie d'adulte de femmes enfin il est
c'est-à-dire il a bercé votre vie à la
maison c'était du giannina la maison du
johnny dans la voiture du johnny partout
elle dit elle madiot manger mais c'était
soirée du joli à toutes les soirées il
ya toujours des chansons de julien à
chaque soir ça c'est le temps tout les
temps qui est tous les français à mieux
dans tout les fans mais c'est vrai pour
tout le monde parce que moi je suis plus
vieux de 47 ans mais du jour je suis né
à aujourd'hui
l'idole des français c'était johnny
hallyday donc c'est un repère même pour
notre société pour pour tout le monde et
là il ya vraiment quelqu'un venait de la
famille mais un repère qui disparaît
alors